[Music]
on this Wednesday night the pandemics
consequences for kids the toll it's
taking mentally and physically I miss
playing with my friends and the
ramifications of keeping children out of
school too long
Canada denied a UN Security Council seat
the significance of this loss our
economic health the details Ottawa could
soon reveal and omit about canvass
finances an Atlanta police officer
charged with murder new developments in
the Rashard Brooks investigation and
kicked in the assets it's been a
nightmare
how small soccer teams are trying to
stay in the game
[Music]
global national with Donna freezing
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with red flags being raised
about the health and well-being of our
children they'd usually be wrapping up
classes now going to graduation
ceremonies and looking ahead to summer
jobs and camps that's all changed this
year and doctors at Toronto's Sick Kids
Hospital the biggest pediatric
institution in the country say the loss
of these important moments of social
development could have a worrisome
impact Mike Armstrong has our top story
tonight
you could probably visit any park in
Canada and find some kids pretty pumped
about school being canceled but as
things have dragged on more and more are
missing classes and everything that
comes with it this girl says she hates
the coronavirus because she can't see
her friends or her teacher well there is
a growing chorus of experts who say
keeping kids at home is doing more harm
than good
remote learning and zoom meetings aren't
enough okay good morning everyone
a panel of experts at Toronto's sick
kids held an online press conference
Wednesday with the message that children
can't wait for a cure or a vaccine
against kovat 19 it's going to be around
for a long time and the alternative of
having children not in school for months
and potentially a year or two I just
untenable now the panel doesn't question
the decision to close schools back in
March knowing what we knew then it was
the right move but it says we now know
more the danger of holding classes
doesn't seem as bad as originally
thought children don't catch the virus
often they're only about 5% of all cases
in Canada and when they do catch it
generally it's mild there have also been
studies around the world showing kids
don't really put teachers at risk
generally
what you see is children get infected
from adults and not the other way around
now the panel says governments are under
estimating the impact of canceling
school they're the physical problems
kids aren't as active but there's also
the mental side of it a significant
proportion of children have experienced
increased depression anxiety
irritability not having kids in school
means vaccines aren't happening when
they're supposed to and
learning disabilities aren't being
diagnosed as early as they could be the
panel says elementary and high schools
should reopen in the fall with
precautions things like more
hand-washing and screening for symptoms
but it says being strict about physical
distancing or masks might have a
negative impact and increase anxiety I
think as a general statement we don't
think that masks should be required
one thing the panel says would help is
telling families and children when
they're going back just getting periodic
updates means waves of hope and
disappointment and again only increases
the stress Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal many kids weren't physically
active before this pandemic now things
are even worse a report card from the
nonprofit group ParticipACTION gives
Canadian kids
a d-plus for overall physical activity
that's based on two years of data ending
in February it found 39% are getting at
least 60 minutes of moderate to vigorous
physical activity per day that's the
minimum to maintain healthy living no
surprise that screen time is a big
factor in children's sedentary behavior
which also score in a D+ ParticipACTION
says parents need to lead by example
they need to set limits for the amount
of time kids spend with devices make a
point of setting aside screen free
family time and not allow screens in
children's bedrooms that not only
invites more usage it also affects the
amount of sleep kids get québec's Chief
Coroner has ordered an inquiry in jacoba
19 deaths in long-term care facilities
and other residential homes for
vulnerable people more than 60 percent
of Quebec's kovat 19 deaths have
occurred in public or private long-term
care homes the inquiry will look at
deaths recorded between March 12th and
May 1st the point is not to lay blame
but determine the cause and circumstance
of the deaths and provide
recommendations on how to prevent it
happening in the future the coroner will
hear testimony in public and will make
the final report available to all was
pandemic is having a massive impact on
Canada's economy and Ottawa has been
under pressure to present a clearer
picture of how bad it really is we do
realize that it's important for us to
continue to be transparent with
Canadians and that's why on July 8th our
we'll move forward to present an
economic economic snapshot of our
current situation to ensure the
Canadians understand where we're at and
help them to have confidence in our
future together it's a snapshot not an
update the prime minister says the
pandemic has created too much
uncertainty to be specific about the
numbers but critics say there is no good
reason to be so vague abigail Beeman
explains what we can expect and what we
won't get we come into this budget we
all know what a budget is most of us
have heard of the lighter economic
update but what the Prime Minister is
promising mid pandemic is something new
on July 8th our government will be
releasing an economic and fiscal
snapshot Justin Trudeau says the
snapshot will pull together what's been
done how other countries are doing and
look forward but just a little I think
it would be a little bit unrealistic to
project much further than than a few
months because things are changing so
rapidly I don't think it's unrealistic
former Parliamentary Budget Officer
Kevin page says Canadians need more
information and given uncertainty the
government could present a few different
scenarios I think we should get a
teaching plan for recovery so you know
to what extent is the government going
to use stimulus to support growth there
have been billions spent on support
programs the Parliamentary Budget
Officer has provided updates on a range
of topics we know the unemployment rate
hit a record 13.7 percent in May and
we've seen two months in a row of
negative inflation but there are still
unanswered questions I mean if the Prime
Minister is brave enough to wade into
crowds I'm sure the Finance Minister
should be able to wade into the House of
Commons and and provide the update
economics professor Livio DiMatteo
points out budgets were tabled during
world wars and those were periods in
some sense of even greater crisis you
know given what was at stake
than what is going on now the dictionary
defines snapshot for a hunter as a shot
quickly taken without deliberate aim
will the debt exceed a trillion dollars
and we are looking forward to providing
information
that will come out in our July 8
presentation questions too about the
extension of the Canada emergency
response benefit and whether it acts as
a deterrent against going back to work
that's why we're beefing up our
attestation to include a requirement on
workers to seek work and to take it when
it's reasonable to do so the Prime
Minister said we're moving through the
emergency phase and towards recovery but
he wouldn't say when we may see a full
budget or an economic update abigail
Beeman
global news Ottawa beyond dealing with
pandemic pressures at home the Liberal
government is also dealing with a major
loss on the world stage it was a close
vote but Canada has failed in its bid to
secure a seat on the UN Security Council
the vote took place today at the United
Nations in New York City Foreign Affairs
Minister Francois Philippe champagne was
there to cast the ballot for Canada it
wasn't enough in a race with Norway and
Ireland for two of the open seats Canada
secured the fewest votes our chief
political correspondent David akin is
following developments for us David
Canada came close but a loss is a loss
what is the theory on why Canada fell
short and couldn't get enough countries
to support us yeah you're right Donna
loss is a loss and it was one of the
closest races that UN watchers tell me
they've ever seen in the history of the
UN let me break it down you need a
hundred and twenty eight votes to get on
the Security Council
Norway got 130 Ireland got 128 right on
the nose and Canada was back at 108 so
now the Canadian government officials
their big question is what went wrong
each country's has 193 different reasons
why they would support one country or
another and this is the you know like
this is the politics of the UN that is
very tricky and very difficult and and
complex and we will have plenty of times
to actually look at that a couple of
things that ambassador Blanchard will
like to look at peacekeeping commitments
and overseas foreign aid Canada's
foreign aid is half and has been for a
long time of what Norway's is and as far
as peacekeeping goes well Canada has
never had so few peacekeepers on UN
missions in more than 70 years and that
matters with the UN voter another
problem with the Canadian bid it started
way too late
Canada
has been campaigning for four or five
years now Norway and Ireland they've
been campaigning for a decade and they'd
already locked up so many votes by the
time Canada came asking for them Donna
David what might this say about Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau who worked so
hard to try to win this seat on the UN
Security Council
well even Prime Minister's own cabinet
was telling him that this bid it was all
on him succeed or fail and foreign
policy experts are telling me tonight
that this is terrible for the Prime
Minister politically because he was so
personally invested in this bid he did
not do a good job explaining why Canada
should have a Security Council seat at
this time and it really only been in the
last few weeks in which he's formed more
formed a more coherent pitch to voters
you know back in 2015 when the Trudeau
Liberals took over they used to go
around town boasting their foreign
policy would be all about Canada is back
well not so much Justin Trudeau joins
Stephen Harper and William Lyon
Mackenzie King as the only Prime
Minister's that failed at their attempts
to win a Security Council seat Donna all
right David akin in Ottawa thank you the
families of the people killed in that
mass shooting in Nova Scotia in April
have filed a proposed class-action
lawsuit against the RCMP and the
province 22 people were killed by a
gunman over a 13 hour period the
proposed lawsuit alleges the RCMP had a
duty to protect the safety and security
of the public and failed that includes a
failure to send timely and appropriate
warnings to the community the lawsuit is
also seeking punitive damages from the
RCMP for the way it handled the
investigation this is the second
proposed class-action lawsuit the
victims families are also seeking
damages against the estate of the gunman
who was killed by police it was a bit of
a wild afternoon in the House of Commons
the NDP leader junk meat Singh was
kicked out after refusing to apologize
for calling the bloc québécois House
leader a racist it's true I called him a
racist Singh was seeking unanimous
consent on a motion about systemic
racism in the RCMP there was at least
one objection that blocked it though
was unclear who said no sing believes it
was the blockhouse you'd apologize and
in that moment I got angry I'll be
honest I got angry I'm sad now because
why can't we act why can't we do
something to save people's lives we can
do something and why would something
know that a fired Atlanta police officer
has been charged with murder and could
face life in prison or the death penalty
if found guilty Garret Rolfe is accused
of murdering 27 year old Rashard Brooks
outside a Wendy's restaurant in Atlanta
last week and a warning some of the
video you're about to see is disturbing
the Fulton County Georgia District
Attorney has issued an arrest warrant
for Garret Rolfe he fired two bullets
into Brooks back last Friday night as
the unarmed black man was running away
Rolf is also facing 10 other charges
including aggravated assault the
shooting took place after Brooks was
found sleeping in his car at a Wendy's
drive-through the district attorney says
Brooks was calm and cordial when police
approached him and cooperated calmly
answering questions for more than 40
minutes
he was never informed he was being
charged with impaired driving the
struggle started when police tried to
handcuff him at one point Brooks grabbed
Rolf's taser and pointed it over his
shoulder as he ran away
the DA has concluded Brooks posed no
deadly threat we have also concluded
that Roth was aware that the Taser and
Brooks's possession that it was fired
twice and once it's fired twice it
presented no danger to him are there any
other persons Howard says after roll
shot Brooks he said I got him that he'd
kicked him while he lay on the ground
and failed to seek medical attention for
more than two minutes a second officer
Devon Brosnan admitted he stood on
Brooks shoulders as he lay on the ground
he is facing three counts of aggravated
assaults and has agreed to testify
against his former
partner both cops have been fired and
are asked to turn themselves in by
tomorrow an alarming trend in the u.s.
coming up the deepening concerns as
kovat 19 cases fries
as the reopening of the economy in the
United States accelerates so are cases
of kovat 19 the rise in positive cases
and in hospitalizations in some states
is deeply worrying as Jackson prosecco
explains with summer looming Americans
are riding a fresh wave of kovat 19 in
Florida a new hot spot a group of 16
friends contracted the virus after a
night out I got it over the last week in
21 states case counts have been on the
rise six of those states reported record
daily increases with troubling trends in
Arizona Texas and Florida each state
reported more than two thousand new
cases per day the curve is rising
sharply and that's not just the numbers
of cases from testing it's being
paralleled by a big rise in the
hospitalizations far from worried most
states are refusing to lock back down in
Tulsa Oklahoma President Donald Trump is
set to hold his first campaign rally in
months
this Saturday even as cases spike the
CDC has said unequivocally that this is
the highest risk event for transmission
of the virus this is a super spreader
event in downtown Tulsa in Texas the
governor blocked any move by local
mayor's to require the use of face masks
all of us have a collective
responsibility to educate the public
that wearing a mask is the best thing to
do putting people in jail however is the
wrong approach the White House has gone
so far as to suggest the virus is under
control if we stop testing right now
whatever a few cases if any but it's not
that simple
Arizona now has one of the highest case
positive rates in the world and hot
weather has shown no signs of slowing
the virus I'm a real proponent now of
dialing up dialing things back getting
people out of the bar getting people you
know away from crowded areas in many
corners of the country that's unlikely
to happen as politics not science drives
the response to the Panda
Jaxson Prosecco global news Washington
Canadian aerospace company CAE says it's
new medical ventilator has been
certified by Health Canada and is ready
to be shipped to hospitals across the
country the montreal based company
signed a contract with the federal
government earlier this year to
manufacture and supply 10,000
ventilators border orders ahead New
Zealand cracks down after new
coronavirus cases pop up
New Zealand has called in the military
to take charge of its quarantine
operations after a major oversight by
health officials they allowed two
overseas travelers to leave quarantine
early on compassionate grounds a pair
later tested positive for Kovac 19 this
case represents an unacceptable failure
of the system it should never have
happened and it cannot be repeated New
Zealand's Prime Minister says border
control policies are being reviewed to
ensure more cases aren't imported
they're also working to track down
anyone the two travellers may have been
in contact with after leaving quarantine
the two women from the UK tested
positive for koban 19 after driving from
Auckland to Wellington a protester in
Britain has been arrested after a fender
bender involving the Prime Minister
Boris Johnson's car was leaving
Parliament when a Kurdish activists ran
towards it the driver stopped suddenly
and was rear-ended by a security vehicle
it caused a dent in the prime minister's
car but no injuries and moments after it
happened
the motorcade moved on soccer shutout
next the pandemic kicks up major fears
four little leagues
you are watching global national tennis
fans won't get to see their favorites
play at the Rogers Cup men's tournament
this year it was supposed to happen in
August in Toronto but has been pushed to
August of 2021
founded in 1881 the men's tournament has
been held every year except for 1905 and
during the first and second world wars
there's some good news for soccer fans
after more than three months on pause
the English Premier League is back in
action and will play the remaining games
of the season in near empty stadiums but
worldwide TV revenue and merchandise
will keep those teams afloat as Redman
Shannon reports dozens of smaller
professional clubs in England and across
Europe could face economic collapse the
world's most watched soccer league the
Premier League is back games are being
played inside echoing empty stadiums
fans can only watch on TV but beneath
those Meggitt clubs are scores of
smaller professional teams like Leyton
Orient with little TV revenue they rely
much more heavily on getting fans in the
door to buy tickets burgers and beers
chief executive Danny Macklin has had to
deal with their season being cut short
and the prospect of an empty stadium
whenever things resume we expect that a
moment Kovach nine teams have an impact
of around about 1.5 million of
additional cash funding that we will
need that we would have had needed if
the cove at 19 had have come they've had
to lose staff and hope fans will pay to
stream games online for the foreseeable
future
yeah I do fear that there could be a
good number of clubs that find the next
few months and potentially season very
very challenging Orient's struggles were
softened by a former player and world
cup superstar Harry Kane
he's now sponsoring the team but most of
England's small teams operate at a loss
that's difficult to sustain in a in a
normal economic environment you go into
a covert world and those problems become
magnified this football finance expert
says many smaller teams rely on money
from trades
so it only takes one club in one country
to go bankrupt become insolvent and then
we could have a domino effect across the
whole of Europe berry FC was founded in
1885 but money troubles have suspended
all football since last year can't
resurrect it we can't get yet going
again
I'm finished with football it's been a
nightmare for that zone what people
don't realize is that a football club is
the biggest community asset in any town
the next six months will determine how
many other football towns face a similar
fate Redman Shannon Global News London
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm donor Friesen we leave you
tonight with a group of grads making
their voices heard in Parliament this
virtual choir of pages led the national
anthem for the House of Commons
last June sitting it's a parliamentary
tradition marking the end of the pages
year working in Parliament this one
ended a little different I hope to see
you here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]